parliamo dei licheni i geni delle
montagne saranno rari o saranno
gironzolando licheni su rieducational
channel
come avete visto dalle foto di instagram
sono diventato un montanaro che bear
grylls può accompagnare solo in questo
momento mi trovo esattamente qui che è
una roba mai vista c'è in realtà in
video non rendono maestre cosa perché di
documentaristi miliardo e mezzo in
realtà non rende dal video sicuro mica
poi una bomba potete capire dal fiatone
del mio obiettivo in realtà io adesso
sono stravaccato su una roccia in questo
momento ma il mio obiettivo in realtà
era questo arrivare sulla punta questo
video vedete è veramente ma veramente un
caso è molto difficile quanto pensassi
l'accesso mio accompagnatore che non
riescono a casumaro si vede lo lascia lì
abbandonato secoli fa proprio
accompagnatore saluta ok bene c'è anche
un cane nel caso si fosse notato che qui
che bello inedito in superare accade
veramente un casino siccome casa fatto
frodo alla bruciare l'anello mordor
perché mica io sto portando un hai un
iphone
già è difficile privarsi l'anello per
una volta sto facendo una roba da human
safari porca [ __ ] human ma come cazzo
fai ma sembra che si sia schiantato un
drago qui c'è qualche a trovare la
montagnano questa la montagna per capire
la grandezza di quel coso
questo è un essere umano questo
questo è un cane bianco che quello che
avete visto nelle foto di staino elice
sia schiantato un drago di politiche
dimostrò pietro è un arresto pietro che
ti penso anche in montagna porta trama
incredibile quanto si sente ma bravo ma
bravo che hai fatto il bagnetto dentro
il lago e ora si tutti infangato bravo e
adesso chi è che ti pulisce ti pulisci
da solo da solo perché si sa che se io
metto la mano in quella merda lì è bravo
e dopo un'ora e mezza di scalata
gli scalate incredibile sono arrivato in
cima senza aiuti sotto par il blog
mentre cammino sulla montagna di giuro
la forza di volontà determinazione si
arriva ovunque
allora ragazze con un equa e alto suo
mezzo dubbio mi sto calando leggermente
sotto però siamo arrivati qua che una
postazione da cecchino che secondo me
merita
vi sono ammazzato per questa montagna
che la vede
ecco qua c'è già anche la dedica mion
lorenzino grazie presente presente
grazie grazie perché hanno già
riconosciuto la mia bravura nelle
scalato quindi anche qui prende madonna
che caga madonna ceca ma vai avanti cane
vai avanti che cai assurdo ma qua destra
non è un problema ea sinistra che un
problema che qua metti che cadi ti fai
malissimo ma non mori perché gli
attacchi a qualcosa al cazzo esempio
quasi storica di salute anche gesù
cristo nel maine
ecco qua mi sa che ci ammazzano per se
cadiamo a destra ricordatevi dio è buono
fritto porto dovremmo new york demonio
dritto dritto dritto se va beh no vabbè
dai cosa faccio mi butto di qua le cane
mi butto che cazzo faccio guida mi fa
qualcosa animale allora cane dimmi cosa
dobbiamo fare
no no no no federico no no no non di
bravi gli incendi perché porca [ __ ] e
non di recupero se diventi frittella di
cana so cazzi tua dritto dov'è che non
c'è una strada c'è un sembra che devo
fare sia uditore cosa devo fare qua qua
ra qua non c'è niente non c'è niente ma
qui non c'è nulla ma no ma non possono
aver fatto una storia così ma porca 3 ma
mette un piede ebbe sei morto così che
cazzo fa il cane torna indietro serie
cazzo vasto rugby go hard ma come ma con
come come come spiega come come
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi quelle erano le montagne
dove siamo scesi oggi e mi sono fatto a
piedi tutta questa discesa fino lì per
una bellezza di 4 ore stava iniziando a
piovere quindi abbiamo corso siamo
arrivati fino in fondo per quattro ore
di discesa a questa divertente una sono
arrivato a casa che non avevo più il
telefono però di resistere torniamo
indietro facendo tutto in salita voi non
avete da il male alle gambe e
sofisticato tutto in salita sotto la
pioggia così inizia da due ore che siamo
in giro
signore e signori dopo due ore di
risalita di montagne il figlio di
[ __ ] è qui pezzo di merda e questo è
il [ __ ] tele che abbiamo chiamato un
miliardo di volte per sapere
premete la vibrazione o almeno lo
sentivamo e adesso vediamo quante
chiamate siamo arrivati a 4 per cento di
batteria 61 chiama madonna gabry ponte
ha messo mi piace il mio post graf fa
l'inchino bizet mi ha mandato un video
ma che cazzo ne vanti video ho perso il
telecheck mortacci dove è stata
un'ottima un'ottima avventura bello
febbre a 40 domani i vari social
[Musica]